thank you kendall this next segment is
for busy moms dads and caretakers
everywhere lifestyle expert ali levin
is sharing some serious mom hacks from
snacks to crafts
and floral decor she's got you covered
while we are cozy
at home for the holidays take a look hi
i'm allie
and i am so excited to be joining
remotely today
to share my mom hacks and holiday gifts
with you
i've got you covered from everything
from crafts to snacks and floral decor
so first i have this amazing craft
studio box by lindsay a mom of three
who knows all about being a busy mom and
wants to bring crafts into your home to
make it squealable fun for your little
ones
and fun for us as adults she knows what
it's like to be a busy parent and
not have me worry about what's next or
what do i do or how is this gonna work
everything is in the box
instructions play by play all the
materials everything you need to have
fun
with your arts and crafts next i have
these amazing couches
my stranded kids we love these couches
my daughter cannot get enough of that
and myself as a mom i love how
convenient they are
and i love how shelf stable they are
and they're easy to take with you in the
car so you don't ever forget a snack
you can have them at the park you can
have them at home
if your kids not a pal cheater put them
on their pasta put it in a blender give
them a smoothie
put it in the freezer make a popsicle
there are so many endless things you can
do with these amazing pouches
they are my go-to mom hack and i love
that they are
premium nutrient dense ingredients as
well as ethically certified
and low in sugar and last but not least
i love
this company the floral preservation
company by theresa
theresa wanted you to preserve your
memories through flowers and she wants
to be a part
of helping the world do it i love this
kit because i think it's such a unique
gift for anyone that has flowers sitting
around
from a wedding from a funeral from a
prom whatever it may be that special
event that meant something to you
these flowers can be preserved from this
kit
it could be fresh flowers it could be
flowers that are being revived up to 10
years ago you can revive them and
preserve them
and use this kit she's got you covered
she's got the floral papers the clips
the mist the shaping tweezers the
diffuser everything you can do at home
so easy and convenient and so much fun
and i love that she also created this
world keepsake album
that you can put the flowers in and
write down your memories and your
beautiful milestones of what was
important to you in that moment
and you can shop at amazon and etsy for
the floral preservation company
i hope you enjoy all these hacks and
gifts and happy holidays to you
you can find me at allyliving.com and
our living design on all social media